WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED ON OUR HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE MEETING --
SORRY AND WE WILL START OF THE
SUB COMMITTEE I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT GOING ON WE ONLY HAVE FIVE
BILLS TO HEAR AND HUMAN SERVICES
SO I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THIS
ALONG WE HAVE --
MISS MITCHELL'S ALREADY HERE'S I
WOULD LIKE TO OUR HONOR AND
RESPECT THE FACT THAT SHE'S HERE
ON TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
MITCHELL.
YES SOLD JUST FORMALLY WELCOME
TO THE JUNE TWENTY SIX HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE WHICH IS THE FINAL
SCHEDULED HEARING --
FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
MY FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
FOR THEIR WORK THIS YEAR TODAY
WE HAVE SEVEN BILLS UP ONE OF
WHICH IS ON CONSENT AS A
REMINDER WE ALLOW TWO WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT AND TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FOR EACH BILL.
EACH OF THESE WITNESSES SHOULD
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO TWO
MINUTES ANY ADDITIONAL IN THIS
IS ME OUT ON THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION BY STATING ONLY THEIR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
AND AGAIN WE'RE STARTING AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MISS MITCHELL
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
THIS HAS GOT TO BE THE CRAZIEST
THEY AYE EXPERIENCE AS A
LEGISLATOR OR AN EIGHT YEAR NOT
OVER YET TO WHERE IT IS NOT.
AND I IF I WEREN'T SO OLD I
WOULD HAVE WORN ROLLER SKATES
TODAY.
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOU GOBBLING DOWN OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN THAT I HAVE
A WITNESS HERE --
TO SHARE HER PERSPECTIVE ON OUR
BILL.
S. B. NINE EIGHT TWO IS A BILL
THAT WOULD INCREASE THE AMOUNT
RECEIVED FROM A CAL WORKS GRANT.
AN EFFORT TO HELP LIFT FAMILIES
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN OUT OF THE
POVERTY.
AS YOU WELL KNOW MADAM CHAIR THE
CURRENT MAXIMUM GRANT LEVEL. FOR
A FAMILY OF THREE IN CALIFORNIA
IS SEVEN HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
DOLLARS A MONTH.
THAT IS NINE DOLLARS LOWER THAN
THE MAXIMUM GRANT LEVEL WAS OVER
TEN YEARS AGO.
IN FACT THE CAL WORKS GRANT HAS
LOST MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF ITS
PURCHASING POWER.
SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WITHOUT A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE GROUT
LEVELS WILL HAVE REMAIN BELOW
THE POVERTY. FOR ELEVEN YEARS IN
A ROW.
WHILE WE AWAIT THE GOVERNOR TO
HOPEFULLY DRESSED THIS ISSUE BY
SIGNING THE BUDGET BILL I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT IN KEEPING THIS BILL
MOVING.
I AM PROUD TO HAVE WITH ME TODAY
BROACH ELEMENT D'ELSA ON AS A
WITNESS WHO WILL --
DO THE MOST THE BRAVE THING IN
THE MOST SELFLESS THING BY
TELLING OF HER PERSONAL STORY
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS FOR CELLO MENDOZA
AND I AM WITH PARENT VOICES OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
SO HELLO EVERYBODY HOME LIKE I
SAID MY NAME IS RICH ELEMENT
DOES A AND I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
ANYA.
I AM A SINGLE DIVORCED MOTHER OF
TWO CHILDREN ELEVEN INTO.
TODAY I'M JOINED WITH OTHER
PARENTS VOICES MEMBERS.
ACROSS OUR STATE TO FIGHT BACK
ON THE PROPERTY [inaudible]
GENERATIONAL POVERTY --
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE GROWING UP AND LIVING
IN POVERTY.
I WAS BORN INTO A FAMILY OF
GETTING IN VIOLENCE [inaudible]
AND CRYING.
MY MOTHER AND FATHER STRUGGLED
WITH THEIR OWN DEMONS --
OF VIOLENCE CRIME ABUSE AND THE
PROPERTY.
AS A YOUNG GIRL.
I WAS LEFT BEHIND ALONE NOT
KNOWING IF MY OLDER BROTHER.
OR MOTHER FATHER WOULD RETURN TO
GET ME.
WE MOVED OFTEN BECAUSE OF THE
NEIGHBORHOODS WE LIVED IN AND
THE VIOLENCE AND CRIME THAT WE
BROUGHT TO THEM.
I DID ATTEND SCHOOL.
BUT DIDN'T HAVE THE SUPPORT OF
PARENTS BEING INVOLVED.
IN MY EDUCATION.
I WOULD HIDE FOOD IN THE CLOSET.
I CAN REMEMBER IT BEING A BOX OF
KICKS FROM THE WAKE THAT MY
MOTHER HAD RECEIVED.
I WAS THERE.
IN THIS CHILDHOOD TRAUMA.
AND NO ONE'S SEEN.
EVEN AS YOUNG AS FIVE OR SIX
YEARS OLD I REMEMBER.
I WOULD SIT IN CLASS HUNGRY.
AND WITH A PAINFUL GROUND.
IN MY STOMACH.
I COULD WAIT I COULDN'T WAIT FOR
LUNCH BECAUSE I KNEW THAT THAT
WAS THE ONLY MALE I COULD I
WOULD RECEIVE [inaudible]
GROWING UP.
ALL I CRAVED WAS TO BE NORMAL
AND TO FIT IN WITH OTHER KIDS.
AS A MOTHER WITH TWO KIDS.
I TURNED TO THAT.
WORKS PROGRAM.
WHEN I NEEDED HELP IRECEIVED
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED A MONTH?
WE CURRENTLY LIVE WITH MY MOTHER
BECAUSE HOW THE HOUSING IN
CONCERT COSTA COUNTY IS VERY
EXPENSIVE. FOR A ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT IT IS ABOUT.
SIXTEEN TO SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
THAT CASH AID I RECEIVED WENT.
TO PAIN UTILITIES FOOD AND GAS.
THERE WAS NO WAY I COULD AFFORD
TO LIVE ON MY OWN.
IF THE CASH GRANT [inaudible]
WAS RAISED.
WHAT I WOULD DO HONESTLY IS TO
PROVIDE OF MY ELDEST SON WHICH
USE?
HE WOULD.
GO AROUND WHICH SHOES THAT
DIDN'T FIT.
THAT HAD HOLES IN THE BOTTOM
[inaudible]
HIS SOCKS.
WOULD GET WET.
FOR BOYS GROW UP SO FAST.
HE WOULD WALK AROUND WITH PANTS
THAT WERE TOO SHORT.
AND HE OFTEN GOT TEASED.
IT BREAKS MY HEART [inaudible]
BECAUSE IT BRINGS ME BACK TO
WHEN I WAS A KID.
I KNOW THE SHAME.
OF WEARING CLOTHES.
THAT DIDN'T FIT.
OF OTHER KIDS TEASING.
MY SON WAS TEAMS.
TO THEIR SELF ESTEEM YOU HAVE.
WHEN YOU CAN WALK INTO A STORE
LIKE WALMART OR TARGET TO BUY
SHOES [inaudible]
ISRAEL.
I AM GRATEFUL. FOR THE GOOD WILL
AND GARAGE SALES.
IT'S WHAT I CAN AFFORD.
BUT THE SHAME AND HUMILIATION.
THAT YOU FILL.
AS A CHILD STAYING WITH YOU
STAYS WITH YOU.
I WOULD ALSO BY [inaudible]
HEALTHIER FOOD [inaudible]
RIGHT NOW.
AT THIS AT THIS TIME --
IT SEEMS LIKE HELP YOUR FOOD IS
[inaudible]
WAY EXPENSIVE.
I SOMETIMES CALL THE FOOD BANKS.
THE SALVATION ARMY.
ENTER JUST FOR FOOD.
IT SHOULDN'T SOUND LIKE A
LUXURY.
TO MEET YOUR BASIC NEEDS LIKE
CLOTHING.
THAT FITS AND HEALTHIER FOOD.
BUT IF YOU ARE [inaudible]
IN PROPERTY [inaudible]
LIKE [inaudible]
WE DON'T.
IT'S IT'S LIKE WE DON'T DESERVE
IT.
I STARTED GOING TO CHURCH.
AND FOUND COMMUNITY TO SUPPORT
ME [inaudible]
I AM.
PARTICIPATING IN THE CAL.
OR WORKSHOP WHERE I CAN SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE TO HELP MAKE THE
SYSTEM BETTER FOR OTHER
FAMILIES.
I'M BEGINNING TO HEAL FROM MY
PAST TRAUMA.
FROM THE MENTAL EMOTIONAL AND
PHYSICAL ABUSE FROM MY EX
HUSBAND.
SO THAT I CAN BE THE BEST
VERSION OF MYSELF FOR MY KIDS.
SO TODAY I ASK FOR YOUR YES.
VOTE ON S. B. [inaudible]
NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT WAS
WONDERFUL THINK.
THANK YOU --
AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SELENA PRIOR WITH SEIU IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DISCOVERED LOW ON BEHALF OF
STRONGER CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
COALITION AND SUPPORT.
KEVIN HAS THEIR COLUSA
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT
THAT.
ONLY SAN LUIS AND HAVE A
CALIFORNIA LATINAS REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE PROCTOR SPONSOR THING
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
HIMMLER'S REPRESENTING CHILDREN
DOWN SUPPORT.
MY CAROL WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
WEST SAM'S UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
MARTHA GUERRERO REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CATHERINE OF ARAGON ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JENNIFER CRAPPIE WITH PARENT
VOICES CALIFORNIA AND ARE
FIFTEEN CHAPTERS ACROSS THE
STATE AS SPONSORS WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THINKING.
AND YOUR MUSE FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KEVIN ENDS CHO IN SUPPORT AYE
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN THE
LUTHERAN OFFICE OF PUBLIC
POLICY.
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE THE CALIFORNIA CHURCH
IMPACT THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS AND THE JEWISH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAUNCEY HAZARD
WHAT THE ALLIES YOUR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS WERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I THINK FANS WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AS
CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT INNER DRIVE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
KAREN LANG ON MAYOR MARK FARRELL
ON BEHALF OF THEIR MARK ON THE
SCENE QUE SIMMONS CISCO IN THE
CURRENT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS BUTTONS PERTAINING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR WAS
IN A CAR MUCH ON BEHALF OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO RUTH WILLIAMS
FLOURNOY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK
WE ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELIZABETH.
THE AFTERNOONWAS SALAS FILLER
WITH CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MEDIA ONE AMERICAN CATTERY
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA DIVISION
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY A BRING UP TO THE GUYS AND
QUESTIONS FROM OUR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE A SINNER
MITCHELL I AM A PRO EITHER I
HAVE ABOUT COOPER ON THIS BILL
AND THANK YOU FOR FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND MAKES MAKES --
SEEN THE REAL FACES THAT WE'RE
IMPACTING MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE
FOR US UP THINK I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING BRAVE ENOUGH TO COME INTO
AND AND TESTIFY.
LOOK YOU THINK I NEED A MOTION.
UP WITH A I'M SORRY WE'RE NOT
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM ISN'T
AS WE GET CARMICHAEL HAD AND GET
MOTION I APPRECIATE THAT AND
JUST MADAM CHAIR IF IN CLOTHING
IF I MAY SAY WE'VE COME A LONG
WAY.
AWAY I THINK ABOUT OF THE YEARS
IN WHICH THE BUDGET WAS --
AND DE DE DEFICIT --
WHERE IT LEGISLATORS WERE FORCED
TO CUT THE ALREADY LIMITED CAL
WORKS GRANT ON I AM PROUD TO BE
A MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE AT
A TIME WHEN WE CAN --
DO BETTER WHEN YOU KNOW BETTER
YOU DO BETTER ARE RECOGNIZING
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN WHO WILL
BE HELPED LIKE THE STORY WE
HEARD TODAY FROM THIS MENDOZA.
ON BASED ON US.
TRYING TO AT LEAST GET THEM.
A 50% OF THE PATH OF THE PARTY
LEVEL THIS BILL AS SIGNIFICANT
AS IT IS IS NOT THE PANACEA WE
HAVE.
YOU KNOW MILES TO GO BEFORE
WE'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE --
EQUAL ACCESS TO ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN BUT HAPPY
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD --
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT OF SB NINETY TWO THANK
YOU AND THEN WE DO WE DO HAVE
QUORUM NOW LOOKING ASSEMBLY
SQUARE INFERNO GROUP BILL.
HERE A DUTCH CHOI [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
LAUGHS [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
I MOTION.
IN A SECOND OF CAN YOU CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DUTCH CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE I'M GONNA
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
THERE'S STONE.
STONE I THURMAN.
THURMOND AYE BILL IS UP THE
BILL'S ITEM WE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO I DON'T.
THINK YOU.
AND SENATOR ITCHELL YOU HAVEN'T
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DO HAVE
ANOTHER BILL MA'AM I APPRECIATE
IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN WE BEGIN OF THE NEXT BILL
ON MADAM CHAIR OF SENATE BILL
TEN EIGHTY THREE ON DEALING WITH
THAT THE RESOURCE FAMILY?
ON A LIKE TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE RECOMMENDED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ARE
REFLECTED ON PAGES SEVEN EIGHT
OF YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HELP WITH THIS.
IT'S A MEASURE THAT WILL
STRENGTHEN THE INTENT OF THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE ALSO KNOWN AS
THE FEE FI ARE --
INITIATIVE --
ESTABLISHED BY THE LEGISLATION
AND ON BY THE ADMINISTRATION
WERE HOPING TO ADDRESS
IMPLEMENTATION HURDLES IN THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL THE RFA
PROCESS.
AS YOU ALL MAY REMEMBER THE CCR
IS AIMED AT ENSURING THAT ALL
CHILDREN ARE RAISED AND STABLE
IN SUPPORT OF HOMES AND WHILE
THE RFA PROCESS HELP.
HELP TO ACHIEVE THAT VISION IN
SEVERAL WAYS IT CREATES A MORE
THOROUGH PROCESS FOR VETTING
POTENTIAL FAMILY PLACEMENTS IN
THE CYCLE OF MULTI HOME
PLACEMENTS FOR YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE.
AND GROUPON SETTINGS.
AND WHILE I STRONGLY BELIEVE IN
THIS NEW DIRECTION FOR OUR CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM THIS TRANSITION
HAS NOT BEEN EASY WE ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE OUR
APPROACH TO CHILD PLACEMENTS.
AS WITH ANY KNEW PROCESS WE ARE
LEARNING BY DOING IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE IMPLEMENT THE RFA
PROCESS AND WE NOW NO WHICH
AREAS THAT NEED ATTENTION IN
ORDER TO ADEQUATELY SUPPORT
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE AND THE
CARE GIVERS WHO STEP FOR THEM.
CURRENTLY THE RFA PROCESS TAKE
FAR LONGER THAN THE ORIGINAL
ESTIMATE NINETY DAYS TO
COMPLETE.
AS OF DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ABOUT 40% OF RESOURCE FOUND THE
APPLICANTS TOOK LONGER THAN
NINETY DAYS TO COMPLETE.
PROBLEM WITH THAT MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THAT FAMILIES ARE
GOING MONTHS BEFORE BEING
APPROVED AS A RESOURCE FAMILY
AND ARE THEREFORE NOT RECEIVING
ANY FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
TAKING THE CHILD.
S. BEATEN AB THREE WILL ADDRESS
THESE IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES IN
THE FOLLOWING WAYS FIRST WE'RE
CLARIFYING THE POTENTIAL
CAREGIVER TO START THE RFP
PROCESS BUT WITHDREW THE
APPLICATION MAY PICK UP WHERE
THEY LEFT OFF WITHIN A TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD.
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENT MAY
REQUEST UPDATED INFORMATION FOR
KEY FROM CARE GIVERS IN THESE
INSTANCES.
WE'RE ENSURING THAT A YOUTH
CAN'T CONTINUE TO BE PLACED WITH
A RELATIVE WORK THEN THE FAMILY
MEMBER THROUGH VOLUNTARY
PLACEMENT AGREEMENT OF EPA'S
WITHOUT.
THE RELATIVE HAVING TO FIRST BE
APPROVED AND WAIT FOR THE MULTI
MONTH RFA PROCESS TO BE
COMPLETED.
ALLOWING FOR THE MONTHS THAT A
CHILD SPENT IN IN A HOME PRIOR
TO THE FALL ARE FAKE COMPLETION
OF THE RELATIVE TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE SIX MONTH CAN GET
REQUIREMENTS.
SO THAT THE RELATIVE MAY RECEIVE
FUNDING AND AVOID DELAYS TO
PERMANENCY FOR YOU.
AGAIN THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT FAMILIES
OF STEPPED UP BOTH RELATIVE AND
NON RELATIVE WHO ARE WILLING TO
TAKE A CHILD INTO THEIR HOME.
THAT THEY NOT BE PENALIZED BY
NOT RECEIVING.
REIMBURSEMENTS --
WHILE THE RFA PRODUCT IS BEING
COMPLETED THERE SOME OTHER
TECHNICAL FIXES IN TERMS OF THE
AMOUNT OF TIME WHERE ALLOWING
COUNTIES TO COMPLETE THE
PROCESS.
ABA WITH THAT WITH ME HERE TODAY
IS A LEASE WEINBERG RIPPING THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
ADELINE JUST LOOK FOR A CARE
GIVER FROM WOODLAND WHO WENT
THROUGH THE RFA PROCESS THINK
AND TELL US FIRSTHAND.
HOW COMPLICATED THE SYSTEM AS A
BEFORE WE CONTINUE --
SENATOR I KNOW MY OFFICE
CONTACTED YOU ARE IN ADDITION TO
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTED
AND THE ANALYSIS THERE WILL BE
ADDITIONAL I'LL COME CONFORMING
AMENDMENTS PER LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL --
EMPLOYED THESE AMENDMENTS ENSURE
THAT ALL FOSTER FAMILIES
INCLUDING BILL CERTIFIED BY
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES AND
LICENSED BY COUNTIES ARE TREATED
EQUALLY.
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT LINE WITH THAT VOCAL IT IS
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE WHO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS EITHER
THROUGH OUR FFA THROUGH THE
COUNTY GET THE SAME YES
ABSOLUTELY FINE WITH THAT THINK
OF IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ELISE WEINBERG I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS.
CONTINUUM OF CARE IS A REFORM
FOUNDED ON THE REALITY THAT
CHILDREN DO BEST WHEN THEY ARE
IN THE CARE OF THEIR RELATIVES
AND OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL TEN AB THREE WOULD
HELP ENSURE THAT THAT VISION
BECOMES A REALITY FOR FAMILIES
ACROSS THE STATE.
SENATE BILL TEND TO BE VERY
MAKES PRACTICAL IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESS IT EMPOWERS FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING DELAYS.
THAT ALLOWS CHILDREN TO ACHIEVE
PERMANENCY FASTER AND IT REDUCES
BARRIERS TO ENSURING THAT
CHILDREN HAVE A TEMPORARY AND
SAFE PLACE SPENT IN A TIME OF
CRISIS.
IN SHORT THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL MORE
FAMILY FRIENDLY AND CHILD
CENTERED JUST AS INTENDED AND
I'M SO PLEASED TODAY TO BE
JOINED BY A LONG DRESS WHEN FOR
A GOOD SHARE HER STORY WE ARE J.
BUT THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS SANDRA SWINFORD AND I
AM HERE TODAY WITH MY HUSBAND
AARON.
HOW WE LIVE IN WOODLAND
CALIFORNIA?
ON JUNE FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE TOOK
EMERGENCY PLACEMENT OF MY EX
HUSBAND'S FOUR YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER.
HAS STARTED THEY ARE IF THEY
PROCESS.
WE HAVE LEARNED THAT THE CHILD
HAD BEEN IN FOSTER CARE. FOR SIX
MONTHS AND WAS LIVING WITH
STRANGERS.
WE IMMEDIATELY WANTED THE TOWEL
TO COME LIVE WITH US.
AND WAS WILLING TO DO ANYTHING
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
MY HUSBAND WORKS SEVENTY HOURS A
WEEK AND THE SELDOM HOME.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
TAKE CARE OF IN ADDITION A
CHILD.
ON TOP OF HER SON AND HER BABY.
THE CHILD ALSO HAS BEHAVIORAL
EACH WHOSE SO WEEKLY THERAPY
APPOINTMENTS WERE NECESSARY.
IN ADDITION TO PARENTAL
VISITATIONS TWICE A WEEK.
HOWEVER WE WERE ABLE TO DO IT
WITH THE HELP OF MY SISTER.
THE REQUIRED CLASSES WHERE
HARDSHIP FOR MY HUSBAND.
ALTHOUGH THE EDUCATION FROM THE
REQUIRED CLASSES PROVIDE THE
MOST IMPORTANT.
TOOLS TO DEAL WITH THEIR CHILD.
HE STILL HAD TO GIVE UP SEVEN
DAYS.
FROM WORK TO FULFILL THE
REQUIREMENTS.
MY THE REQUIRED CLASSES WHERE
HARDSHIP FOR MY HUSBAND.
WE ALSO COMPLETED THE REQUIRED
INTERVIEWS THERE WERE NO
ADDITIONAL CLASSES WE HAD TO
TAKE.
WE HAD DONE EVERYTHING WE HAD TO
DO.
HOWEVER WE STILL SOMEHOW MANAGED
TO FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS.
WE GAVE OLIVER REQUIRED
DOCUMENTS TO OUR FIRST SOCIAL
WORKER.
WHO LEFT HER JOB AFTER A THREE
MONTH?
WHAT THE NEW SOCIAL WORKER TOOK
HER PLACE?
THERE WAS LOS PAPERWORK AND LONG
DELAYS IN COMMUNICATION.
SHE ASKED US FOR DOCUMENTS THAT
WE HAD ALREADY SUBMITTED TO THE
PRIOR SOCIAL WORKER SUCH A THIRD
LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION.
I FELT LIKE WE WERE AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE PILE.
IT TOOK OF NO MORE THAN THREE
MONTHS TO SUBMIT EVERYTHING TO
THE SOCIAL WORKER BUT IT TOOK
SEVEN MONTHS FOR US TO BE IN THE
POSITION TO BE APPROVED.
ALL THE WHILE THE CHILD WAS
MISSING OUT ON SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES.
FOSTER GET COULD HAVE OFFERED
HER.
EVEN THEN THERE WAS THEM
ISCHEMIC MISCOMMUNICATION BY THE
SOCIAL WORKER SAYING WE WERE
APPROVED.
AND ONLY TO FIND OUT AT A LATER
POINT THAT WE WERE NOT NEVER
APPROVED.
THIS IT'S A VERY NON FAMILY
PROCESS TO CAREGIVERS.
THERE NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND OVERSIGHT OF THE PROCESSES.
S. B..
TEN EIGHTY THREE WILL ENSURE THE
TIE THAT TELL WELL FIRST
AGENCIES.
ACCOUNTABLE TO A NINETY DAY TIME
TIMELINE WHEN RELATIVES AND NON
RELATED EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS
ARE GOING THROUGH THE RFA
PROCESS.
IT WILL ALSO ALLOW THE COURT TO
HAVE MORE OVERSIGHT OF THEIR RFA
PROCESS.
THE FAMILIES CAN GET THROUGH
THEIR APPROVAL PROCESS QUICKER.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH THE ALL TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO PASS
HAS BE.
TEN EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
IS THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
TEMAS THEIR COLUSA CALIFORNIA
FOR RIGHTS ORGANIZATION STRONG
SUPPORT THINKING.
CAN LESS REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH IN A SPIRIT
THAT AND SUPPORT.
YEAH THAT'S FOR THE CHILDREN'S
LAW CENTER CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR
AND SUPPORT.
WILLIE COLBY CALIFORNIA COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER GRABBY WITH PARENT
PLACES CALIFORNIA AND ARE
FIFTEEN CHAPTERS ACROSS THE
STATE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I THINK BANDS WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GEN RIGHTS ROAD CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CAREGIVERS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
KATE SEEN UNDER BRING IT UP TO
THE DICE AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND SENATOR OF MITCHELL IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO I'M SORRY.
TYPE STUFF JUST A BRIEF COMMENT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD WAS YOU POINT OUT WITH
CC ARE REALLY THE PROMISES HERE
WAS THE REFORM RIGHT.
BUT ALSO THE ONGOING COMMITMENT
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT CHALLENGES FOR
IMPLEMENTATION.
THIS IS CLEARLY ONE OF THEM THAT
WE HAVE FORCE IS HERE TO WORK WE
NEED.
FAMILIES AND MAKING THEIR THEIR
LIVES EASIER THE PATH EASIER IS
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO BE
COMMITTED.
TO THANK YOU I A. AYE ECHOED --
MISTER STONE'S COMMENTS --
THROUGH THE PROCESS I'VE SEEN SO
MANY DIFFICULTIES AND WE HAVE
FAMILIES THAT ARE A WILLING AND
ABLE TO TAKE CARE FOR THE
CHILDREN I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE SERVE.
AYE AYE IN MY OPINION SHOULD BE
START --
GIVE GIVE THEM THE RESOURCES
FIRST AND THEN WE CAN CONTINUE
WITH THE PROCESS AND SO --
THANK YOU US IN OUR MITCHELL FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND MOVE
AYE I'M GLAD TO BE WORKING WITH
YOU AND I AM ALSO SIT ON SUB ONE
WHICH IS THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WHICH PROVIDES THE
FUNDING FOR THIS AND THERE IS A
A MUCH DISCUSSION --
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
FAMILIES GET COMPENSATED
PROPERLY SO THAT THEY CAN CARE
FOR THESE CHILDREN.
AND WITHOUT --
WE DO HAVE A DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL
ONSITE CAN.
I KEEP DOING YOU IT'S OKAY LIKE
THE FACT THAT I LIKE I LOVE FOR
YOU I LOVE TO ROW EXACTLY NOW
LIVE TO REST TO A VOTE EQUIPMENT
IN MY FAVOR --
IT AND YOU KNOW THAT MR STONE
LET ME SAY THAT I STOOD BY
YOU'VE BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
STAND BY YOU AS WE AS WE FIGURE
OUT -- HOW
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS BRAND NEW
VERY DIFFERENT WORKS?
CHILDREN IN ON FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AND THE ADULTS THE CARING
ADULTS WHO WE ARE ASKING TO STEP
UP.
AND ON PROVIDE A FAMILY SETTING
FOR THEM YOU KNOW HEARING
STORIES LIKE THAT A HEART
BREAKING.
AND I AM CLEAR THAT THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT THE NORM BUT WE
SHOULDN'T --
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT HAVE SO MANY
GAP THAT TOO MANY CHILDREN
FAMILIES FALL THROUGH IT THAT'S
THE FOCUS ON OF THIS BILL TO TRY
TO CLOSE. ONE OF THOSE GAPS TO
MAKE SURE THAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE WHILE THE FAMILY IS
PROVIDING CARE IT'S NOT SAYING
THAT YOU DON'T GO THROUGH THE
RFA PROCESS WITH THE WHOLE POINT
OF OUR FATE.
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT IT REALLY
IS AN APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT IN
THE EYES OF THE CHILD SO WE
WOULD PROVIDE THE RESOURCES
WHILE YOU'RE PROVIDING CARE
OUGHT.
MAKE SURE THE RFA PROCESS ITSELF
IS WELL OILED THEY WELL OILED
MACHINE UNFUNDED.
AMONG THE THANK ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND AND THE
COUNTIES THAT THAT HAVE STEPPED
UP BOTH FOR THIS BILL IN THE
PREVIOUS BILL.
BECAUSE IT'S WORKING TOGETHER
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT STATE
GOVERNMENT STAKEHOLDERS AND
BENEFICIARIES OF THESE PROGRAMS
IS HOW WE GONNA GET SYSTEMS THAT
WORK FOR EVERYBODY WITH THAT
MADAM TRAPS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE [inaudible]
RUBIO.
REVEAL AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI I HAVE I'M GONNA.
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
THERE'S STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE BILLS KEPT
FORTITUDE THANK YOU THE BILL'S
OFF WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
I MEAN MEMBERS TO ADD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CASE SENATOR GLAZIER
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
YOU'RE IN A VERY BUSY DAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SOME HIGH HERE
TO PRESENT THAT THIS BILL THAT
GUARANTEES CAL WORKS BENEFITS TO
CAL WORKS RECIPIENTS WHO MEET
FEDERAL WORK REQUIREMENTS.
NOW FEDERAL LAW SETS THE AMOUNT
OF OUR SOMEONE RECEIVING
CALVERT'S BENEFITS MUST WORK OR
ATTEND SCHOOL. FOR EXAMPLE A
SINGLE PARENT WITH A CHILD OVER
THE AGE OF SIX MONTHS WORK
TWENTY HOURS A WEEK.
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE BENEFITS.
IN CALIFORNIA CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS ARE REQUIRED TO
DEVELOP.
A WELFARE TO WORK PLAN.
PUT THEM ON A PATH TO BECOME
SELF SUFFICIENT.
HOWEVER IF A RECIPIENT FINDS
WORK BEFORE THEIR PLAN ALLOWS
BEFORE THEIR PLAN ALLOWS.
THEIR BENEFITS ARE REDUCED
THROUGH A SANCTION.
PER MONTH THE FUNDS ARE THEN
REDUCE TO NAME A ALSO LOSE
ACCESS TO OTHER VALUABLE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES SUCH AS
CHILDCARE AND TRANSPORTATION.
SOME COUNTIES ALLOW SANCTION CAO
WORKS RECIPIENTS.
DEMONSTRATE GOOD BECAUSE AND NOT
COMPLYING WITH THEIR INTENDED
PLAN THIS COMPLACENT UNFAIR
BURDEN ON WORKING RECIPIENTS.
THEY'RE USUALLY STARTING NEW
JOBS THAT PREVENT THEM FROM
MEETING WITH COUNTY WELFARE
AGENCIES DURING BUSINESS HOURS
IT'S ALSO DIFFICULT TO ASK FOR
TIME OFF.
FROM AN EMPLOYER IF THE EMPLOYEE
IS NEW TO THE JOB.
JUST LAST YEAR THEY DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES ARE VAGUE
FOUND THAT THIRTEEN HUNDRED CAL
WORKS RECIPIENTS ACROSS THE
STATE WERE BEING SANCTIONED.
EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE MEETING
FEDERAL WORK REQUIREMENTS.
THE SANCTION PROCESS CAN BE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO HELPING
PEOPLE GET BACK ON THEIR FEET.
PUNISH CAO WORKS RECIPIENTS FOR
WORKING.
AND DISCOURAGE THEM FROM FINDING
EMPLOYMENT SOONER.
THIS BILL GIVES CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS.
DIFFERENT ROUTE TO GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET WITHOUT BEING
PUNISHED FOR DOING SO.
SPILLS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IT HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND RECEIVE NO NO VOTES
THUS FAR AND I ENCOURAGE YOUR
FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION.
OKAY OFTEN KEVIN AS THE CHORUS
OF CALIFORNIA BOTH RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION.
THIS CAME TO ATTENTION SEVERAL
YEARS AGO WHEN THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES REVEALED THAT
THREE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
NINETEEN PEOPLE.
WERE MILLING MEETING THE FEDERAL
STRINGENT BOTH WORK
PARTICIPATION RATES WHILE ALSO
BEING SANCTIONED PUT DURING
THAT.
SECTION MEANS THAT FOR FAMILY OF
TO YOUR BENEFITS GOES DOWN FOR
FIVE SIXTY A MONTH THAT TO PAY
FIFTY FIVE A MONTH.
MEANWHILE MANY OF THEM ARE
WORKING OF MEETING THE FEDERAL
WORK PARTICIPATION RATES IN
ORDER FOR THAT TO CURE THE
SANCTION.
AND FOR EXAMPLE IF THERE WAS
SECTION BECAUSE THEY CAN GO TO
CHOP CLUB.
WHEN THEY WERE ASKED TO GO THERE
[inaudible]
THERE WERE.
YOUR TO TO THE SECTION THEY HAVE
SUPPORTER CHAPTER FOR THREE
WEEKS.
WELL YEAH.
WE HAVE A CHOICE YOU GO TO WORK
LEGAL JOB CLUB WHICH WOULD WHY
DO YOU CONTINUE TO WORK.
SO THEY SHOULD NOT BE SANCTIONED
THIS BILL WOULD BASICALLY SAY
INFINITE WP A FEDERAL WPR.
NO SANCTIONS WE GOING TO COMMUTE
CHILDCARE AND TRANSPORTATION.
THANK YOU FOR VERY MUCH FOR
DOING THE RIGHT THING.
LARGE DRIVE BOTH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
STOP.
MADAM CHAIR MICRO WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE
CONCUR IN THE COMMENTS ON THE
STRADDLING ME AND YET THIS SEEMS
LIKE A VERY COMMON SENSE MEASURE
TO US -- IF
SOMEONE IS MEETING THE WORK
QUORUM IT'S IS WHAT CAN WE
SHOULDN'T BE SANCTIONED.
AND IT ALSO SEEMS SOMEWHAT
FOOLISH TO US THAT WE WOULD BE
REQUIRING COUNTY WORKERS TO BE
PURSUING THESE KIND OF CASES
WHEN THERE ARE SO MANY MORE
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT CAN BE
DONE TO HELP LIFT UP OTHER
FAMILIES.
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND URGENT AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I THINK BETH WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS THE SPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
KAY I'LL BRING IT UP TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
OKAY HEARING MONDAY MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY HAVE URGENT AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY I HAVE A MOTION
THAT THE FUNDS ARE GOOD I GUESS
I CAN AFFECT.
KICKING CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
[inaudible]
REVEAL.
I TO REVEAL I GOT CHOI NAY I
DUCKED CHOIAYE I'M GONNA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
DAIS STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THE BILL IS A BILL IS OUT AND
WILL KNOW WHEN DID YOU SAY I
THURMOND AYE.
ADDING UP THE BILL IS OUT BUT
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OF AN FOR
OTHERS TO I DON'T THINK YOU
MISTER.
OKAY -- WILL
GO AHEAD AND DO CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER STONE A SECOND BY MISTER.
A THURMAN OF FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CAN CALL THE ROLL.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE DOCTOR CHOI
DUCK TO CHILL I AND I'M GONNA.
MAIENSCHEIN THERE'S STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE [inaudible]
WE'RE OUT KATE.
WE HAVE --
FOUR VOTES FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR --
SENATOR WIENER IS TIED UP LIKE
WE ALL ARE.
RUNNING AROUND TODAY AND HE WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO PRESENT AND HE
ASKED FOR SPECIAL CONSIDERATION
FOR US TO FOR THAT HAS --%
TO LET HIS STAFF --
PRESENT ON HIS BEHALF
[inaudible]
I DOING [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OF YEAH I MISS SKINNER'S I'M
HERE I'M INSULT SOUL I AM IN
LIGHT OF OUR SCHEDULES I I WOULD
--
LIKE TO LET THEM PRESENT ON HIS
BEHALF.
AND UNLESS THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ARE THERE
[inaudible] TO THANK
YOU PRIME DOING.
I WILL JOIN YOU ON THIS ONE HAVE
THAT.
AS A JOINT AUTHORED AT THIS BILL
I WOULD LIKE --
TO TALK ABOUT --
SB WHAT NINE EIGHTEEN WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE ROOT CAUSES FOR WHY
YOUTH ARM TO HOMELESS WE COME TO
FIND THAT THEY ARE DRASTICALLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE REASONS WHY.
ADULTS FIND THEMSELVES IN THE
STREETS THESE YOUNG ADULTS --
THESE YOUNG ADULTS A LEFT TO
FEND ARE LEFT TO FEND FOR
THEMSELVES OFF THE FACE BARRIERS
GETTING AN EDUCATION OR SECURING
A JOB AND ARE IN HIGH RISK OF
BECOMING VICTIMS OF PHYSICAL AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THAT'S BECAUSE WITHOUT SAYING
THAT HOMELESSNESS CAN HAVE LONG
LASTING EFFECTS ON A YOUNG
PERSON'S.
CHANCES OF SUCCESS THAT IS WHY
WE CAN AND MUST DO MORE FOR
THESE YOUNG FOLKS --
NO CHILD SHOULD BE FORCED TO
SPEND A SINGLE NIGHT ON THE
STREETS AND IT IS UNACCEPTABLE
THAT ONE IN TEN OF CALIFORNIA'S
USED -- ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS RIGHT
NOW AND I I PRESENTED ON THIS
CASE BEFORE ON THIS ISSUE BEFORE
WE HAVE AS OF TODAY WE HAVE
FIFTEEN THOUSAND KIDS THAT DON'T
HAVE A PLACE TO TO TO LIVE --
IT IS VERY HOT TODAY --
BUT WHEN WE ORIGINALLY STARTED
THE PROCESS OF THE SPELL I
REMEMBER THAT DAY WAS A
EXTREMELY EXTREMELY COLD AND
RAINY.
AND SO I WE ALL WERE RUNNING
HOME AND TRYING --
TO MAKE SURE THAT --
WE GOT OUT OF THE RAIN AND
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THEY DON'T
HAVE.
SO --
INQUIRED --
ALONG WITH I SENATOR WIENER AYE
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK OF FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND WE HAVE --
HIS OFTEN YEAH OF THE PRESENTERS
THANK YOU.
I LIKE SAID I THINK THE CHAIR IN
THE COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR WIENER.
AND YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH THE
BILL'S SAGA AND INTRODUCE OUR
WITNESSES AYE WE HAVE.
AT PATRICK CHEN HERE --
OF FORMER HOMELESS YOUTH AND
THEN WE ALSO HAVE A KIM LUIS
REPRESENTING THAT AND THAT
CALIFORNIA COALITION FREAK
TODAY.
AND HELLO THANK YOU --
MY NAME IS PATRICK CHEN GOT IT
AND IN --
FEBRUARY OF TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN I WAS JUST FINISHING
UP MY SENIOR YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL
WAS MY LAST HALF OF THAT SENIOR
YEAR.
WHEN I RECENTLY TURNED EIGHTEEN
AND I WAS KICKED OUT OF MY HOUSE
IT WASN'T FOR ANY DRUGS ANY
MISBEHAVIOR AT SATURDAY?
IT WAS BECAUSE I WAS HAVING SOME
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND MY
FAMILY WAS NOT RECEPTIVE TO IT.
I LIKE MANY --
KIDS WHO ENDED UP ON THE STREET
HAD A LONG HISTORY OF ENTERING A
PIECE FROM FAMILY AND HAD GROWN
UP POOR AND IMPOVERISHED.
I DIDN'T REALLY HAVE ALL TOO
MANY TOOLS NAM BUT ONE THING I
DID HAVE WAS I HAD CONNECTIONS
AT MY SCHOOL AND I WAS GOOD AT
RESEARCH.
SO I JUST SO HAPPEN TO BE ABLE
TO BE HELPED BY TOM WINDY YOUTH
SERVICES THEY ARE THE ONLY A
DROP IN AND EMERGENCY --
YOUTH SHELTERS IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY --
AND I CAN QUITE AUTHORITATIVELY
SAY THAT THEY SAVED MY LIFE.
THEY ONLY HAD SIX BEDS AT THE
TIME.
OUT OF THE HUNDREDS ALMOST
PROBABLY THOUSANDS OF KIDS IN
OUR COUNTY WHO WERE SLEEPING ON
THE STREETS ARE BOUNCING BETWEEN
FRIENDS HOUSES LIKE I WAS BEFORE
[inaudible]
THE THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE SAME
LUCK I DID TO BE ABLE TO GET ONE
OF THOSE SIX BATS [inaudible]
AND WHEN YOU SERVICES WASN'T
JUST A ROOF OVER MY HEAD.
THEY WERE ALSO CARRYING IN
SUPPORT OF STAFF --
THEY WERE VERY.
WONDERFUL TO ME THEY HELPED ME
TO LEARN HOW TO BUDGET THEY
HELPED ME TO LEARN HOW TO TAKE
CARE OF MYSELF --
TO HELP ME GET TO AND FROM
THERAPY THEY HELP ME GET TO AND
FROM THE HIGH SCHOOL I GRADUATED
--
I ACTUALLY GRADUATED I'M I
THOUGHT FEW HONORS AWARDS AND I
WAS A STRAIGHT A STUDENT AND I
WAS ABLE TO MAINTAIN THIS
BECAUSE I HAD HELP FROM WHEN DO
YOU.
AND FOR THE SIX MONTHS I WAS
THERE I SAW IN IN OUT KIDS
COMING IN AND AND THEY WERE
CHEST MOST OF THEM WERE EITHER
IN FOSTER CARE.
ON THEY WERE CAME FROM
IMPOVERISHED BACKGROUNDS THEY
WERE ABUSED.
IT WAS JUST THERE WERE JUST SO
MANY OF THESE KIDS THEY HAD SUCH
DISTRUST TOWARDS ADULTS THEY'D
BEEN THROUGH SO MUCH AND THEY
DESPERATELY NEEDED THIS HOW.
SOME OF THEM EVEN LIKE HAD A
HARD TIME BEING RECEPTIVE TO THE
HELP WHICH WAS SO WELL CURATED
BY WHEN THE AND IT BREAKS MY
HEART TO THINK THAT.
OF ALL OF THE HOMELESS YOUTH
LIKE A IN OUR STATE VERY FEW OF
THEM HAD ACCESS TO THE HELP
WHICH IS THE REASON WHY I AM
CURRENTLY --
STARTING MY SECOND YEAR OF
COLLEGE I AM A JOURNALISM MAJOR
AT SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE ON I
HAVE MY OWN APARTMENTS AND I
LIVING WOODLAND AND AYE I
RECENTLY.
I'VE BEEN SPEAKING ON COUNCILS
OF MICE LOCAL CITY COUNCIL FOR
THINGS I'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO SO
MUCH.
AND I WOULD NOT BE HERE I WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO DO ANYTHING ANY
OF THIS I MOST LIKELY WOULDN'T
BE HERE ON THIS EARTH IF IT
WEREN'T FOR WIND YOU'VE SERVICES
HELP AND THIS BILL.
WOULD HELP FUND THEA THING
SIMILAR TO WINGS YOUTH ALL
ACROSS [inaudible]
THE STATE [inaudible]
SO.
THE HELP I RECEIVED THIS
LIFESAVING HELP AND SUPPORT
WHICH I RECEIVED TO BE ABLE TO
BECOME A FUNCTIONING ADULT.
WON'T JUST BE BECAUSE I WAS
LUCKIER I HAD THE RIGHT
CONNECTIONS.
IT'LL BE AVAILABLE TO JUST ABOUT
ANY.
STRUGGLING COUGH --
KID WHO IS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND I I HOPE THAT
YOU WILL VOTE AYE FOR THIS.
UP PROPOSAL IT WOULD MEAN SO
MUCH NOT ONLY TO ME BUT TO JUST.
HOW MANY KIDS OUT THERE WHO
DON'T EVEN HAVE AN IDEA THAT
THIS COULD BE POTENTIALLY SAVING
THEIR LIFE AND A YEAR OR SO
THANK YOU?
THANK YOU.
NEXT CAMERAS THAT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION PREET WHEN
THE PART BECAUSE SPONSORS ON THE
BELL AND WHEN THEY THINK THE CO
AUTHOR OF A BOOK AUTHORED CHAIR
AND SENATOR WIENER AS WELL THAT
THE CO AUTHORS ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
FOR I'M SUPPORTING THE SPELL AND
AND DOING MORE FOR NOW WE HAVE
THE LAST STATEWIDE SURVEY NOW
THAT ONLY TWENTY AT THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES
AT SERVICES OF ANY KIND LIKE --
PATRICK WAS TALKING HERE ABOUT
AND SUPPORT OF OUR YOUTH
EXPERIENCINGHOMELESSNESS AND WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S OVER A
PRESENTATION OF YOUTH OF COLOR
AND LGBT YOUTH WHO ARE ON THE
STREETS AND WE CAN AND SHOULD DO
MORE TO REALLY COMBAT THE ISSUE
OF CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT 50% THE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS ADULTS.
FIRST EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
WHEN THEY WERE YOUTH.
BETWEEN THE AGES OF EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR AND SO ON I THINK IF
YOUR TIME ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE AND HOPE THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN REALLY.
SET A PRESIDENT ONLY POLICY TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES BE THE
EXPERIENCE OF HOMELESSNESS THINK
IS A MUCH.
THANK YOU AND YET THOUGH. FOR
SUPPORT WITNESSES.
UP BROWN AND MARTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WE HAVE HOMELESS YOUTH
COORDINATOR WORKING WITH YOUTH
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIPS THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL.
PAUSES CUBA FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
STATUS FEATHER CHILTON'S LAWSON
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU KEITH DOWN HERE FOR MY
CLIENT TO CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THINKING FOR THE
BILL ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
A WET SAM'S HERE WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON WILLIAM WATSON
BURKE WITH EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL WE WANT I THINK I SENATOR
WIENER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
FOR THIS OP FOR MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MAX PAID CITY OF LONG BEACH ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACK ANDERSON
WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
SHANTI HAS RUN WITH THE ALLIES
ARE CHILDREN TRIES WHEN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BETSY WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
ISTINA MARSELLUS ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. FOR MY
TAPING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN FROM ON
BEHALF THE COMPTON UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HIGHS AND IMMEDIATE ME HERE WITH
THE BECAUSE THE STATE
ASSOCIATION WITH AND SUPPORT.
KAREN LANG ON BEHALF OF MAYOR
MARK FARRELL IN THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IT'S
PART.
DANIELLE CAN A KAISER BEHALF OF
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CHRIS MARTIN A CO SPONSOR ON
BEHALF OF US THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND HOUSING
CALIFORNIANS OR THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES SO IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
HER.
IF NOT THEN --
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS SO HORROR
[inaudible]
OPINIONS.
OKAY ANYONE OR LOCKED ALL J. M.
HOW IT'S A MEMO THURMOND.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LIKE.
TO I THANK THE CHAIR AND SENATOR
WIENER --
FOR UP LEADING THIS BILL AND I
THINK PATRICK.
UP FOR INCREDIBLE TESTIMONY IN
FOR ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE AND UP ALL THE
SPONSORS AND STAKEHOLDERS --
YOU KNOW IT --
YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT MOST OF MY
CAREER PURPOSE YOUNG PEOPLE FOR
WHOM HOUSING INSTABILITY HAS
BEEN.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES THEY FACE
IN THE REAL TIME THE MIGHT OF
BEEN OTHER REASONS FOR WHY THEY
CAME TO THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
WORKED IN BUT IT'S HARD TO MAKE
IT WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE SECURE
HOUSING A PLACE TO STAY IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
AND SO THAT YOU KNOW IN THE
COUNTIES WHERE I WORKED WE
TYPICALLY HAD --
SOME SHELTERS CIVIL TO THE ONE
THAT YOU DESCRIBE THE FEW BITS
BUT ALWAYS A LONG WAITING LIST.
AND WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS BILLS
AT A BILL THE FRAMEWORK TO
REALLY A CREATE THE TOTAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HOW TO
SUPPORT YOUTH HOW TO DO
PREVENTION.
HEADED DO INTERVENTION HOW TO
SUPPORT YOUNG FOR THE INPUT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE AND SO --
I THINK I'M A JOINT AUTHORED THE
BILL BUT IF I'M NOT AT CERTAINLY
LIKE TO BE --
IF YOU ARE WILLING TO HAVE ME --
AND ON BEHALF OF MANY YOUTH FROM
FOSTER BACKGROUNDS MELODY BEATTY
Q. BACKGROUNDS OUR KIDS OF COLOR
AND OTHERS WHO FIND THEMSELVES
WITHOUT A PLACE AT THE THIS IS A
GREAT BILL AND I HOPE THAT --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR GREAT WORK.
DO NOT MAKE A MOTION I WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL OUR SECOND
IT.
MADE THIS QUESTION FOR THE HONDA
MOTION.
IF NOT DONE WHICH TO OKAY
RECOMMENDED TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
LOOK [inaudible]
PRIEST ACQUITTAL.
YEAH OKAY NOW OR CLOSER CLOSING
STATEMENT AFTER THAT THANK YOU
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE [inaudible]
OKAY LOMA [inaudible]
KNOWS AND THE REVEALED NOTHING I
REVIEW I DOCTOR CHOI AYE DOCTOR
CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN THERE'S STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE BILLS GET FOR THIS
YEAR.
COMING UP ABA MISTER WEINER HAS
A SECOND OF
THANK YOU GO HAVE
EXCELLENT I THINK YOU TURN
MEMBERS FOR WELCOMING --
ME ON BEHALF OF SENATOR WIENER
TO PRESENT SB --
SEVEN TWENTY SIX SB SEVEN TWENTY
SIX MODERNIZES OUTDATED LANGUAGE
THAT RESULTS IN REALLY
QUESTIONABLE DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES FROM CAL WORKS AND
ADDITIONALLY --
IN CASES WHERE CHILD SUPPORT
CURRENTLY AS GARNISH TO REPAY
CAO WORKS THAT --
THE FORMER COWARDS CHILDREN HOW
THEIR INCOME SEIZE TO REPAY
THEIR PARENTS OR GUARDIANS DEBT
SO SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX TACKLES
THESE TWO PROBLEMS ON FIRST BY
CLARIFYING THE COUNTY PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATORS CAN MAKE A
DECISION TO ADMINISTRATIVELY
WAIVER EXPUNGE CAO WORKS OVER
PAYMENTS.
IF IT'S ADMINISTRATIVELY
EFFICIENT TO DO SO SIMILAR TO
THE WAY WE HANDLE CAO FRESH
OVERPAYMENTS --
ADDITIONALLY MODERNIZES THE DEBT
COLLECTION THRESHOLD FROM THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS SO THAT COUNTY STOP
LOSING MORE MONEY.
TRYING TO TIME COLLECT THAT I'M
MORE MONEY THAN THEY'RE
RECEIVING.
ADDITIONALLY --
THE LASTLY THIS ENSURES THAT
ONLY THE INDIVIDUAL RESPONSIBLE
FOR A CAL WORKS OVER PAYMENT
HASTA REPEAT THAT DEBT.
WHICH WILL PROTECT CHILDREN FROM
BEING.
FOR BY PROTECTING CHILD SUPPORT
FROM THIS PRACTICE ON THIS IS A
COMMONSENSE SPELL THAT WILL MAKE
ISSUING PUBLIC BENEFITS BOTH
MORE FAIR TO THE RECIPIENTS AS
WELL AS MORE COST EFFECTIVE.
AND COLLECT POTENTIALLY
VULNERABLE CHILDREN OR YOUNG
ADULTS --
FOR THE THAT.
LACK OF PAYMENT YOU KNOW ON
BEHALF OF THEIR PARENTS --
THANK YOU TO THE SPONSORS OF THE
SPELL OF THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY FOR THEIR
ADVOCACY ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL
AS TESTIFYING TODAY.
ARMS OF SPEAKING WITH ME IS MY
CARROLLTON THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AS WELL AS KEVIN
FUNNY AND FROM THE COALITION FOR
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION YES AND BEFORE WE
CONTINUE I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT --
MISDEMEANORS ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT YES THERE'S A SMALL
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT THAT HE IS
ACCEPTING THANK YOU THINK YOUR
PSYCHOPATHIC --
MADAM CHAIR MICHAEL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY I I THINK OUR SUBSTITUTE
AUTHOR HERE DIDN'T EXCELLENT JOB
OF OUTLINING THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL --
ONE THING THAT WE WOULD JUST
LIKE TO BRING TO THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION ANY ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT THIS HAPPENED THIS THERE
ARE PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL.
ABOUT THE RECRUITMENT OF
OVERPAYMENTS FROM CHILDREN --
WE ACTUALLY HAD A CASE LIKE THIS
WE HAVE SEEN MANY CASES LIKE
THIS OVER TIME WHERE CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN HAD.
AN OVERPAYMENT PURSUED INTO
THEIR ADULTHOOD WHEN THEY BECAME
A POWER IN IT BECAME PART OF
THEIR OWN COWARDS FAMILY IN THE
FUTURE.
ON CHASING DOWN IN ADULTS
[inaudible]
CIRCA.
AND WE WERE KIND OF FRANKLY
SHOCKED THAT THIS WAS HAPPENING
WITH THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM SO --
FORTUNATELY THE COURTS AGREED
WITH US AND MR WIENER NOW AGREES
WITH US AND WE'RE HOPING THAT
THIS BILL WILLTHEN BECOME THE
LAW AND THAT THAT WOULD NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN TO ANOTHER CHILD ON
CAL WORKS.
SO WE'RE URGING AND I VOTE FOR
THIS TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO KEVIN I THINK CHORUS A
CALIFORNIA BOB RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION WE HAD A SIMILAR
CASE WERE.
ON THE BELT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OLD HAD THEIR OWN INCOME TAX
RETURN WITHHELD.
WHICH I FORGOT Y. BOOK. TEN
YEARS AGO DIFFERENT TACK
OVERPAYMENT.
SO NOW THEY TOOK THE INCOME TAX
RETURN THAT'S KIND OF WHAT THE
COMMENCEMENT.
BENEFIT IN THE AT THE TIME THE
CHILD WAS BUT A FIFTEEN OR TEN
YEARS OLD WHATEVER.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT THAT
THIS BILL DOES MAKE SURE THAT.
WE DON'T SPEND A HUNDRED DOLLARS
TO COLLECT TWENTY DOLLARS.
EFFECTIVE BUTTE COUNTY THIS
SPENT MORE MONEY ON COLLECTION
THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THEY
COLLECT.
AND THAT'S BAD.
THE MADE THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD
NOT OPERATE THAT WAY.
SO THEREFORE WITH SUPPORT THE
BILL NURTURED AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL CANDLE
BECAUSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SHOULD NOTE THAT THE LACK OF
COMING UP WITH BECAUSE THE TWO
COMMITTEES HAPPENING IN THE SAME
TIME YEAH.
THANK YOU --
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY HOPING IT UP TO THE GUYS
FOR ANY QUESTIONS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
GET.
HEARING NONE I HAVE OF MOTION
THE SECOND CAN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE I'M GONNA
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
THERE'S STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE BILL WAS UP
PORTANTINO THE BILLET OUT FOR UP
FOUR ZERO WILL LEAVE THE POLL
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
AND I
AS SENATOR SKINNER'S NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO A JOIN US I
WILL BE.
PRESENTING ON HER BEHALF
.
OKAY SENATOR SKINNER GO AHEAD.
AND I'M GOING TO HER COMMITTEE
SIZE AIP APPROVE WHATEVER I'M OF
PRESENTING TO EARLIER --
ALRIGHT LET'S SEE SO I WILL GO
AHEAD AND START --
THEY'VE TAKEN TECHNICAL MINUTES
WHICH HAVE REMOVED THE
OPPOSITION CAL WORKS AND CAL
FRESH ESSENTIAL ESSENTIAL IN
KEEPING FAMILIES AND FED INC
BOARD --
THEY WORK A MINIMUM OF TWENTY TO
THIRTY HOURS PER WEEK --
THAT SEE THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL.
IS TO PROTECT PARTICIPANTS FROM
LOSING THEIR BENEFITS AND WHEN
LEAVING AN UNSAFE AND VOLATILE
WORKPLACE TO IT INSURANCE
COUNTING HUMAN SERVICES THAT
NAME FROM INFORMS PARTICIPANTS.
ARE THEIR RIGHTS AND REMEDIES
WHEN THE WORKPLACE VIOLATIONS
OCCUR [inaudible]
AND HERE.
IF YOU CAN HELP ME OUT HERE
BECAUSE SIX PURPOSES THING
[inaudible]
YES --
RECALL YOU MADAM CHAIR NOVI YOUR
IT'S A PUBLIC RECORD --
THANK YOU MICHAEL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY --
AND SO -- WE
VIEW THIS BILL WITH AN ESSENTIAL
PROTECTION OF CAO WORKS
RECIPIENTS WHO ARE REQUIRED BY
LAW FEDERAL ESTATE LAW TO HAVE
TO WORK.
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE THEIR CASTE
SYSTEM.
BUT THERE ARE SOME CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT THAT ARE CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS GET INTO.
WHICH I'M REALLY KIND OF A
BRIDGE THERE THEIR EMPLOYMENT
RIGHTS IN THEIR COUPLE THINGS
ALL AT MISTRANSLATED AND SPEAK
TO THIS ALSO.
BUT I THINK THERE ARE TWO SUCH
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE REALLY
WORRY ABOUT ONE IS THE
UNPREDICTABILITY OF SCHEDULED
HOURS.
SO WE FREQUENTLY SEE --
SOMEONE WHO THE COUNTY WILL SAY
THEY'RE GONNA GET TWENTY HOURS A
WEEK AT THE FOR THE TARGET STORE
WELL GUESS WHAT THEY ONLY GET
SCHEDULED FOR TWELVE HOURS A
WEEK THREE WEEKS IN A ROW AT THE
TARGET STORE.
THEY CAN'T CONTROL THE
SCHEDULING OF THE TARGET MANAGER
DOES -- THAT
CAN LEAD TO A SANCTIONED SO I
THINK SOMEONE WITH UNPREDICTABLE
SCHEDULING OUGHT TO BE PROTECTED
FROM A SANCTION AND IF THEY HAVE
TO LEAVE THAT JOB.
BY BEING ABLE TO COME TO THE
WELFARE OFFICE AND AND AND TELL
THE WORKER LOOK I HAVE TO QUIT
THIS JOB I HAVE TO BE ABLE. TO
NOT BE SANCTIONED BECAUSE MY
HOURS ADJUST TO UNPREDICTABLE
AND THEN I THINK THE OTHER THING
THAT WE SEE ARE THERE ARE.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS WHO TEND NOT TO I AM
--
ENFORCE ALL THE LAWS THAT.
EVERYTHING FROM THE MINIMUM WAGE
TO WORKERS COMPENSATION TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY VIOLATIONS ALL
OF THESE ARE THINGS THAT WHEN
THEY ARE VIOLATED COME MOST
WORKERS --
WOULD HAVE A GRIEVANCE WILL BE
ABLE -- TO
CHALLENGE THAT BEHAVIOR --
BUT IF IT HAPPENS OFTEN TO
ACCOUNTS RECIPIENT BECAUSE THEY
FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE TO MEET
THEIR HOURS THEY DON'T CHALLENGE
THAT BEHAVIOR THEY ARE NOT ABLE.
TO DO IT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEIR
WORKERS' RIGHTS THAT ALL OF US
OTHERWISE ENJOY SO THIS BILL
WOULD GIVE THEM.
CLEAR ABILITY TO DO THAT AND TO
BE PREVENTED FROM BEING HAVING A
SANCTION IMPOSED BY THE COUNTY
DUE TO SOME BEHAVIOR OF AN
UNSCRUPULOUS EMPLOYER WE ARE
CHEN IVA.
THAT KEVIN NOTHING CLARISSA
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION THE PRIMARY PURPOSE
OF THIS BILL [inaudible] TO
PROVIDE SAME WORKER PROTECTION
--
PROTECTIONS THAT REGULAR WORKERS
HAVE THAT WELFARE RECIPIENTS
WILL ALSO HAVE WHEN THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO WORK IN THEIR TO
WORK OFF THEIR WELFARE CHECK.
THE MEN OF WHAT THEY DO THAT
PICKED A WELFARE CHECK THE
DIVIDE IT BY THE MINIMUM WAGE IN
THIS EVERY MONTH YOU HAVE TO
WORK THESE MANY HOURS.
THAT'S FINE WE'RE WORK BUT JUST
GIVE US THE SAME.
THE RIGHTS THAT OTHER WORKERS
HAVE -- AND
IF THE SANCTION BASICALLY IF
THEY GET SANCTIONED IN THEIR
BENEFITS GO THAT PROVIDES FIVE
THINK THAT MONTH.
THAT THREE FIFTY FIVE A MONTH
BENEATH AND THE HOMELESS AND
THAT'S BAD TO SO WE ARE TONIGHT
VOTE THANK YOU.
OKAY S. M. --
WOMAN NOT A CHAIRPERSON NOW
RUBIO IS --
REPRESENTING THE SANTA SKINNER
ANY OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES.
ANY WITNESSES SAYING OPPOSITION.
OKAY MEMBER QUESTIONS SOMEONE
STATEMENTS.
MOVED AND SECONDED THAT HEN THE
WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO MIKA CLOSING STATEMENT
RESPECTFULLY ASK WE ARE ABLE.
OKAY LOCAL BUT YOU ARE.
RUBIO MOTION AYE REVEAL AYE
DOCTOR CHOI.
NO DOCTOR CHOI I KNOW ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO RAYOS
[inaudible]
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND I BILLS GOT FORTY TWO
MILITIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A AND THAT
WAS THE LAST POSSIBLE --
GO HEAD AND DO OPEN THE ROLE FOR
ADAMS.
ITEM NUMBER ONE ASSUME US SENATE
BILL ONE SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR
MACK MCGUIRE.
DO PASSAGE DISH SHERRY COMMITTEE
RECOMMEND CONSENT.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATE BILL
SEVEN TWENTY SIX SENATOR WIENER
--
A RECOMMENDATION DO PASSED
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RAYOS.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SENATE BILL
NINE EIGHTEEN SENATOR WIENER TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
ARAMBULA AND I'M GLAD I
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN I ITEM NUMBER FOUR
S. B. NINE TWENTY SIX SENATORS
SKINNER.
WE'VE DONE THAT ONE RARE SLOPE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SHOULD A BILL
NINE EIGHTY TWO CENTER MITCHELL.
DO PASSED IN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HI.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I ITEM
NUMBER SIX SCENARIO ATTENDED
THREE SENATOR MITCHELL DO PASSED
AS AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE THERE'S ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY SIX SENATOR
GLAZER. TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ARAMBULA.
CAMPBELL LA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I READ.
I THINK IT WILL GO HAVE LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR AN ADDITIONAL
MEMBER. FOR ANOTHER FIVE
MINUTES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR HELP WITH WITH.
THIS YEAR AND AND THE COMMITTEE
APPRECIATED
ROLL UP FOR FIFTEEN
MINUTES SO THAT I CAN GO
PRESENTED A COMEBACK
.
WELL GO AHEAD AND IN THE ROLE.
AND THE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SP ONE SEVENTY
FIVE TO THEIR REQUIRED TO
PASSED.
JUDICIARY RECOMMEND CONSENT
RESTS BY RACE I ITEM NUMBER TWO
SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX SENATOR
WINNER. TO PASS JUDGMENT IT TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SENATE A REYES [inaudible]
REYES I ITEM NUMBER THREE SENATE
BILL NINE EIGHTEEN SENATOR
WIENER TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SENT UP
[inaudible]
RAMPS I'VE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SENATE BILL NYE
TWENTY SIX SENATORS SKINNER DO
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
HARASS [inaudible]
REYES I I NUMBER FIVE SENATE
BILL NINE EIGHTY TO SENATOR
MITCHELL TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE REST
[inaudible]
PRESS I ITEM NUMBER SIX SENATE
BILL TEN EIGHTY THREE SENATOR
MITCHELL TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AYE
RANCH AYE REYES AYE.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SAID ABOUT
FOURTEEN FORTY SIX SENATOR
GLAZER TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE RASH.
REST I WOULD [inaudible]
CLOUD.
WE'LL PUT IT IN A GERMAN FOR THE
REST OF THE YEAR.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP IN THE COMMITTEE THAT'S ON
OH ABSOLUTELY